let me move on to to Pakistan now we've
recently seen the election of Imran Khan
as uh as the Prime Minister and lots of
different reactions to that some people
are hopeful that he's going to be able
to change the country some people saying
he's just - do you know Patsey of the
military where do you stand on Ron Carly
well I I was a strong supporter of him
Ron when he captained the Pakistan
cricket team and in fact when he asked
my advice soon as he was you know he was
about to retire and we had lunch and he
said what do you do he said people like
you don't care about age or anything you
just carry on but for our sportsmen we
have to think of the future so what do
you think I should do and be honest with
me I said I said Imran my advice is to
use your influence and money to set up a
Film Institute in Pakistan so we create
young filmmakers and stars and you
yourself could be the head of that and
also become an actor like Amitabh Bachan
in India some money and he said by
contact I said that is no bar because
very few actors can actually act you
know there the director tells them what
to do so it's a bar so he said yo yo yo
you're pulling my leg I said I promise
you I'm not he said I want to go into
politics
I said dirty messy and in Pakistan this
is Pakistan we're talking about and I
don't think you get very far where he's
proved me wrong he's become the Prime
Minister of the country so he has got
very far but in terms of what he can do
circumscribed by the army and by
probably one of the most corrupt
political classes in the world they are
so corrupted they admit it and you know
the privately they joke with each other
how come that Nigeria became the most
corrupt country on the on the list the
UN sponsored less we've beaten them so
far every time perhaps we should have
brought
the people who make the list to make
sure we remained on the top this is the
degree of cynicism so what is poor imran
going to do I mean you know he can't
it's his politics doesn't come to him
naturally if he just builds more
hospitals it'll be a step forward let's
say that but in other ways you know the
people in his party the members of their
his Foreign Minister currently has been
a foreign minister under military
governments in every other civilian
government it's the same small group of
people who are rotating so he has not
been able he won the support of lots of
young people none of them are in the
leadership doing things they should be
encouraged to do so it's I think I fear
I hope I'm wrong but I think it's going
to be it it will end badly